in a salon scirocco mozza Denmark for
some neon noventa y el estudio main ste
Hadas as you say on apprehending after
Filner beastie for opal some flattening
Eden back when mal para su Lancer to
strike ligula somewhere shul insurance
el de will give Donna to cost Oh Lucy
scenarios a day or sun had will soon
need in Hoonah or hell femme sauna or
sun will take only ignore sevilla from
or the Danish government has proposed to
amend the national law to ensure that
any personal items of sentimental value
will not be ceased off asylum-seekers
this is crucial and as we also heard
from the Commission representative is
something that we will keep a close look
about since Europe does not have a
system which share responsibility for
Refugees the situation is turning into a
race to the bottom where all Member
States seem to try to compete to be the
least attractive country for Refugees in
the hope that they will go somewhere
else on your proposals we've seen the
UNHCR and the Commissioner for Human
Rights of the Council of Europe and
giving a strong critique to the
proposals yep sorry mas not that easy
General Tom depose Dominis share a post
a new status for Absalom oppa se reporta
[ __ ] so flagrant avec le travail
avec le little open
my tips to do